phase 3 of Marvel superhero series is
under way with the release of Captain
America Civil War and it's fair to say
excitement levels are high however
despite the careful years of planning it
seems changes still need to be made to
the phase 3 lineup I'm Simon and this is
your superhuman news updates since the
initial phase 3 announcement from Marvel
we've seen quite a few changes to the
lineup there's been the addition of two
new movies spider-man homecoming due out
next year and ant-man and the wasp Jew
in 2018 we also learnt last month that
Disney is officially removed in humans
from its current list of Marvel phase
three films now it appears there'll be
some changes to the next Avengers
installments as well Joe and Anthony
Russo will see their second Marvel
directed film captain america civil war
release in the US this week the two
brothers are also on board to helm the
Avengers infinity War part 1 and 2 but
the titles may be a little different
when those movies open in theaters in an
interview uproxx asked the Russo
brothers how they decided where to split
the two movies apart to which the
director said they're two very different
movies and they're calling them to
different parts is misleading the
directors have said before that despite
the back-to-back filming schedule the to
infinity war movies are separate stories
Joe confirm that they will change the
titles before they hit theaters the
intention is we will change it we just
haven't come up with the titles yet but
yes we will change it and yes that is a
scoop we will retitle them what do you
think the next Avengers film should be
called Avengers 3 the man in the iron
man mask winter tailor soldier spy hot
tub war machine I'm sure you have better
ideas so feel free to leave them in the
comments or come find me on Twitter i'm
at the jagan or thanks for watching and
for your entertainment news keep it
gamespot